Part B determine the x-coordinate of the
point at which G has an absolute maximum
on the interval negative 4 is less than
or equal to X is less than or equal to 3
and justify your answer so let's just
think about it in general terms if we
just think about a general function over
an interval where it could have an
absolute maximum so let me draw some
axes over here and I'm speaking in the
general in general terms first and then
we can go back to our function G which
is derived from this function f right
over here so let's say that these are my
coordinate axes and let's say we care
about some interval here so let's say
this is the interval that I care about a
function could look something like this
a function could look something like
this and in this case it's absolute
maximum is going to occur at the
beginning of the interval or a function
could look something like this it could
look something like that and then the
absolute maximum could occur at the
endpoint of the interval or the other
possibility is that the function looks
something like the function looks
something like looks something like this
at which point the maximum would be at
this critical point and I say critical
point as opposed to just a point where
the slope is zero because it's possible
that the function is not differentiable
there you could imagine a function that
looks like this a function that looks
like this
and it maybe wouldn't be differentiable
there but this still would be that still
that point there still would be the
absolute maximum so what we really just
have to do is evaluate G at the
different endpoints of this interval to
see what how high it gets or how large
of a value we get for the G at the
endpoints and then we have to see if G
has any critical points in between and
then evaluate it there to see if that's
a candidate for the global maximum so
let's just evaluate G at the different
endpoints so let's start off let's
evaluate G at negative 4 at the stand of
the lowest end or the starting point of
our interval so G of negative 4 is equal
to 2 times negative 4 plus the integral
from 0 to negative 4 f of T DT the first
part is very easy
two times negative 4 is negative 8 let
me do it over here so I have some so I
have some real estate so this is equal
to negative 8 and instead of leaving
this as 0 to negative 4 f of T DT let's
change the let's change the bounds of
integration here especially so that we
can get the the lower number as the
lower bound and that way it becomes a
little bit more natural to think of it
in terms of areas so this this
expression right here can be re-written
as the negative of the integral between
negative 4 and 0 F of T DT and now this
this expression right over here is the
area under F of T or in this case f of X
is or the area under F between negative
4 & 0 so it's this it's this area right
over here and we have to be careful
because this part over here is below the
x-axis so this we would consider
negative area when we think of it in
integration terms and this would be
positive area so the total area here is
going to be this positive area minus
this area right over here so let's think
about what this is so this area this
section over here we did this in Part A
actually this section this is a quarter
circle so it's 1/4 so these are both
quarter circles so we could multiply 1/4
times the area of this circle the area
of this circle of this entire circle if
we were to draw the entire thing all the
way around it has a radius of 3 so the
area of the entire circle would be pi
times 3 squared or would be 9 pi 9 pi
and of course we're going to divide it
by 4 multiplied 1 by 1/4 to just get
this quarter circle right over there and
then this area right over here the area
of the entire circle the area of this
entire circle we have a radius of 1 so
it's going to be pi times 1 squared but
just PI R squared so it's going to be PI
and we're gonna divide it by 4 we're
going to divide it by 4 because only
one-fourth of that circle and we're
going to subtract that so we have
negative pi and we were multiplying it
times 1/4 out here because we're it's a
quarter circle in either case and we are
subtracting it because the area
is below the is below the x-axis and so
this simplifies to this is equal to 1/4
times 8 pi which is the same thing as 2
pi I do that right 1/4 times 8 pi so
this all simplifies to 2 pi so G of
negative 4 G of negative 4 is equal to
negative 8 minus negative 8 minus 2 pi
so clearly a negative number here more
negative than negative 8 so let's try
the other bounds let's see what G of
positive 3 is let's see what G of
positive I'll do it over here so I have
some more space so G of positive 3 when
X is equal to 3 that we go back to our
definition that is 2 times 3 plus the
integral from 0 to 3 f of T DT and this
is going to be equal to 2 times 3 is 6
and the integral from 0 to 3 f of T DT
that's this entire area so we have
positive area over here and then we have
an equal negative area right over here
because it's below the x-axis so the
integral from 0 to 3 is just going to be
0 you can have this positive area and
then it's going to become and then this
negative area right over here is going
to completely cancel it out because it's
symmetric right over here so this thing
is going to evaluate to 0 so G of 3 is 6
so we already know that our starting
point G of negative 4 that when X is
equal to negative 4 that is not where G
hits a global maximum because that's a
negative number we already found the end
point where G hits a positive value so
negative 4 is definitely not a candidate
3 X is equal to 3 is still in the
running for the x coordinate where G has
a global absolute maximum now what we
have to do is figure out any any
critical points that G has in between so
points that are it's either
undifferentiated is equal to 0 so let's
look at it if so G prime G prime of X we
just take the derivative of this
business up here derivative of 2x is 2
derivative of this definite integral
from 0 to X of F of T DT we did that in
Part A this is just the fundamental
theorem of calculus this is just this is
just going to be this is just going to
be plus plus
f of X right over there so it actually
turns out that G is differentiable over
the entire interval you give any x value
you give any x value over this interval
we have a value for f of X f of X isn't
differentiable everywhere but there's a
definitely f of X is defined everywhere
over the interval so you'll get a number
here and obviously two is just two and
you add two to it and you get the
derivative of G at that point at the
interval so G is actually differentiable
throughout the interval so the only
critical points would be where this
derivative is equal to zero so let's set
this thing equal to zero so we want to
solve the equation I'll just rewrite it
actually so we want to solve the
equation G prime of X is equal to zero
or two plus f of X is equal to zero you
can subtract two from both sides and you
get f of X is equal to negative two so
any X that satisfies f of X is equal to
negative two is a point where this where
the derivative of G is equal to zero and
let's see if if f of X is equal to
negative two at any point so let me draw
a line over here negative two and
negative two we have to look at it
visually because they've only given us
this visual definition of f of X doesn't
equal negative two Justin equal to
negative two only equals negative two
right right over there right over there
and it looks like we're at about two and
a half but let's get exact let's
actually figure out the slope of the
line and figure out what x value
actually gives f of X equal to negative
two and we could figure out the slope of
this line fairly visually we can figure
or figure out the equation of this line
fairly visually we can figure out slope
if we run if we run three so change in X
if our change in X is three then our
change in Y our rise rise is negative
six
change in Y is equal to negative six
slope is rise over run or change in Y
over change in X so negative six divided
by 3 is negative two it has a slope of
negative two and that actually I could
have done that easier where if we go
forward one we go down by two so we
could have seen that the slope is
negative two so this this part of f of X
we have Y is equal to negative two x
plus
and then the y-intercept is pretty
straightforward this is at 3 1 2 3 plus
negative 2 X plus 3 so where where the
part of f of X where clearly it equals
negative 2 at some point of that this
part of f of X is defined by this line
obviously this part of f of X is not
defined by that line but to figure out
the exact value we just have to figure
out when this line is equal to negative
2 so we have negative 2x negative 2x
plus 3 is equal to is equal to negative
2 and remember this isn't this is what f
of X is equal to over the interval that
we care about if we were talking about f
of X over there we wouldn't be able to
put negative 2x plus 3 would have to
have some some form of equation for
these circles but over it right over
here this is what f of X is and now we
can solve this pretty pretty
straightforwardly so we could subtract 3
from both sides we could subtract 3 from
both sides and we get negative 2x is
equal to negative 5 divide both sides by
negative 2 you get X is equal to
negative 5 over negative 2 which is
equal to 5 halves which is exactly what
we thought it was when we looked at it
when we looked at it visually it looked
like we were at about 2 and 1/2 which is
the same thing as 5 halves now we don't
know we don't know what this is we don't
know if this is an inflection point is
this a maximum is this a minimum so
really we just want to evaluate G at
this point to see if it gets higher than
when we evaluate G at 3 so let's
evaluate G let's evaluate G at 5 halves
so G at 5 halves is going to be equal to
2 times 5 halves 2 times 5 halves plus
plus the integral from 0 to 5 halves
from 0 to 5 halves of F of T F of T DT
so this first part right over here the
twos cancel out the twos cancel out so
this is going to be equal to this is
going to be equal to 5 and then plus the
integral from 0 to 5 halves now you
might be able to do it visually but we
know what the value is of f of T over
this interval we already figured out the
the the equation for it over this
interval so it's the integral of
negative 2x plus 3
tea and then let's just evaluate this
let me get some real estate so this is
me draw a line here so we don't get
confused so this is going to be equal to
five plus and then take the
antiderivative the antiderivative of
negative two x is negative x squared so
negative let me do it so we have
negative x squared and the
antiderivative of 3 is just going to be
3x so plus 3x and we're going to
evaluate it from 0 to 5 halves so this
is going to be equal to 5 plus and I'll
do all of this stuff right over here
I'll do this stuff in green so when we
evaluate it at 5 halves this is going to
be negative of 5 1/2 squared so it's
going to be negative 25 over 4 plus 3
times 5 halves which is 15 over 2 and
then we're from that we're going to
subtract this evaluated at 0 but
negative 0 squared plus 3 times 0 is
just is just a 0 so this is what it
simplifies to and so what do we have
what do we have right over here so let's
get ourselves let's get ourselves a
common denominator
let's click a common denominator right
over here it could be 4 so this is equal
to 5 is the same thing as 20 over 4
minus 25 over 4 and then plus 30 plus 30
over 4 so 20 plus 30 is 50 minus 25 is
25 so this is equal to 25 over 4 and 25
over 4 is the same thing as 6 and 1/4 so
when we evaluate our function at this
critical point at this thing where the
were the slope where the derivative is
equal to zero we got six and one fourths
which is higher than 6 which is what G
was at this endpoint and it's definitely
higher than what G was at negative 4 so
the x-coordinate the x-coordinate of the
point at which G has an absolute maximum
on the interval negative 4 to 3 is it is
X is equal to 5 halves